I got a chance to see Ford vs. Ferrari
this weekend and I loved it great it's a
fantastic movie and I sometimes have to
watch a show or a movie because
someone's coming on the program and I
have to sort of walk my way around it I
visited some of those this movie is
flat-out great it I fantastic yeah I'm
really happy with how it turned out and
I'm not really a car person so when I
read the script and loved it that much I
knew I knew there was something you
don't have to be a car person I'm not a
car person right you know I mean I have
a lightning bolt on the side of my Prius
this does that make it go faster no it
doesn't but man it's a lady magnet but I
know what I what I loved about it is
it's just a great story and the
relationship between you and Christian
Bale's characters incredibly I mean
that's what draws you in you don't have
to be a car person to love this movie
yeah it's the Christian plays this guy
Ken miles and I play Carroll Shelby and
Shelby was obviously by the end of his
life a very famous car builder
Carpinteria yeah and he and but ken is
lesser-known and he was this great
engineer and driver who helped Shelby
build the gt40 which is the one they
took to LeMond in 1966 to try to write
the central story is forward at the time
not an internationally respected brand
up there with Ferrari those people that
are making these amazing Swiss watches
for cars and then you guys have this
challenge can we build a car that can
beat Ferrari it's a great story I have
to say one of the most tense scenes in
the movie for me is as great as the
racing scenes are you have a fight scene
with Christian Bale and he is such a
kinetic actor who I would imagine is
such an intense personality I'm thinking
I would be afraid to have a fight scene
with Christian Bale you know
yeah he's the safest person to have a
fight scene with because he's
unbelievably professional so Oh Kerry
and this fight is was one of my favorite
fights and I would at the risk of
speaking for him one of his two because
it was it's the opposite of Batman
fighting Jason Bourne yes
yeah really fun
when you hear that Matt Damon and
Christian Bale have a fight scene you
think of this incredibly intense and
it's them it's the it's to real people
having what a real fight looks like guys
who don't fight guys who don't fight
guys who don't fight who actually like
love each other and are great friends
and have an old friendship so it's it's
more like the way you fight with your
brother yes where you're like there's
this line that intuitively you know you
know where it is yeah and sometimes you
hit a little too hard and it's like
sorry yeah you know that we use again
you still want to hit them but you just
you don't want to really hurt them but
what I love too is it Christians
character is carrying a bag of groceries
when the fight breaks out with you so
you're both using the groceries that he
has in his bag right to hit each other
yeah and there's actually a moment where
I reach and I reached out he's getting
the better of me so I reach out and grab
this it's like a can of corn and I like
look at it and realize I don't want to
hit him with that that would really hurt
yeah I grab the Wonder Bread which is
the worst weapon in the world yeah I
will kill you with Wonder Bread I mean
Jason Bourne could probably do it he
could probably figure out a way to soak
the Wonder Bread real quickly like with
friction turn it into a rope of bread
right and strangle you yeah a Wonder
rope yeah wonderful you're gonna get a
call to promote that you know I know
that you're from the Boston area as am i
and there's this reputation that like
Boston guys know how to fight I'm always
going way out of my way to say no I do
not I was in one fight in my life I did
very very poorly very quickly and this
is mine was in the North End of Boston
did you ever get in any fights as a kid
I'm like you I really tried to avoid
them because there are people in Boston
who really do know how to fight yes and
and and you know if you're one of them
or not
and so but no the last fight I got into
who would have been in the in the
mid-80s and we had I remember it we had
a snow day at school so we would all
meet in in the Cambridge common and play
tackle football you know because there
would be a foot of snow on the ground
and so it was kind of like it hurt yeah
I really
so so it was a really fun thing to do
and I mouthed off to a kid that I knew
he but he was he was like you're Heidi
was like six foot six right and I might
have been five three at the time and and
I said some I scored on him or something
and I don't know I said something but I
but he he came for me and it was like
this mountain of a guy came at me and I
was like oh man
so before I knew it it was like I was on
the ground he was he was above me and I
was like this is gonna be bad and it was
right then that little five-foot - Ben
Affleck tackled this dude off of me well
like out of nowhere I was like a junior
and he was like a freshman and and he
tackled this kid off of me
and literally at the risk of his own
life and really quickly then everyone
had broke it up because they wanted to
get back to like the football game
because I was fun and I was ridiculous
right and so he so that was the end of
it and the kid was reasonable and he was
a god I'm not fighting let's let's play
but I remember that was like a big
moment going like this guy is like he
will he will put himself in a really bad
spot for me like this is a good friend
and he will be Batman yes so that was
the other time
exactly